all right let's go to the phones for the
last time of the year last time we are
taking live calls for 2018 at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's start with our caller from
the 3-1 to area code call her from 3 1 2
who's this where you calling from hi my
name is uh Devin what's going on Devin
well uh emphasis on your show so I keep
it short
you know everyone's talking about 20 20
now and all that good jazz and you know
you know just dismissing all the you
know all the garbage who thought about
light was it gonna help the burning on
winning out of he's gonna run on blah
blah I think it looks like he's probably
going around I mean he's got as what
about me send emails that's what
donation is talking about running baby
not running but I digress
what do you think is gonna happen if he
actually gets into office what happens
after that if Bernie Sanders gets into
office yeah everyone talks about we want
burns to get in the office but what do
you think he would logically be able to
do was up a Congress do you think he
would have right if he actually managed
when the White House is it was you know
I'm not not you know not really an
office in a you know January 2021 yeah I
think that you're asking the right
question in the sense of if you have a
president who wants Medicare for all and
a $15 minimum wage whatever else can
they actually get it done and it really
comes down to what's going on in the
House and Senate and as we've talked
about before the Senate is still going
to be an uphill battle for Democrats in
2020 it's a slightly more favorable set
of you know one third of the Senate up
every two years it's a slightly more
favorable set of races for Democrats but
at the same time there's a lot of strong
Republican incumbents so even though you
have more seats Democrats could win most
of them are in pretty red states so can
can president Bernie Sanders and a
Democratic House even one that's more
overwhelmingly Democratic than the one
we're going to have starting in 2019
can they get Medicare for all
if they don't have the Senate I mean
know that the answer is no and we could
kind of go through the policy ideas down
the line but that's a very reasonable
question I honestly wouldn't worry about
it yet let's first see if Bernie's
running before we figure out how he's
going to be as president all right Devin
thank you for the call appreciate it
great to hear from you one of today's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below